[Music]
are you guys
ready for the vaccine yep
what vaccine i'm ready for round two
[ __ ] give me the syringe and stick it
in my dick
oh they got the aids vaccine the tip no
not aids
i'm ready for the aids vaccine yeah i
think we've been ready for that for the
day
i don't know if i don't know if i would
take the vaccine so early
yes that's what i'm saying i'm ready for
round two because there's some it's so
early it's so rushed it's not fda like
through its regular testing yeah there's
not it's not officially fda approved
uh no we do know what the side effects
are the term long-term side effects
no no one will know until what you've
got to give time uh
so there's two front runners right now
for the vaccine there's a company called
visor and also a company called moderna
or moderna
not for sure moderna modern
moderna yeah that's how that's how i
think it's and i'm also scared because
every time i get the flu shot i get the
flu same
no i don't get the flu shot i don't get
the flu i feel like i'll give you
coronavirus then is that the uh i think
she cares
about what it does it gives you posters
i think it's the it gives a mild it's an
active dead version
yeah but the point is it gives it to you
no but it's it's not active it's like
but like it's still technically going
inside your body is what i mean
yes like whatever it is of the
coronavirus it's enough for the
your body to form cells to fight it yeah
from antibodies antibodies
well the side effects here the the not
the long term but there's you know
immediate side effects here
are uh fatigue myalgia
and headaches and my algae is like uh
pain
in muscles that [ __ ] you get that from
the vaccine
from the vaccine it seems like it causes
your body to just kind of like
hurt i already have this i think i have
it i have the vaccine
okay well then i guess you're okay with
this vaccine yeah my
i'm oh my back always hurts so bad
true true and i'm so tired people are
are calling this
the uh uh or the the the side effects
they're calling it
a really bad hangover that's what
they're uh man
[ __ ] that i'ma just get some sun and
broccoli
and zinc that's good zinc i don't know
how long yeah like how long do you think
i wonder because if it's like one day
like an actual hangover or like a few
hours or whatever
then um is there anybody really lining
up to take this first though
i feel like the rpg the people that are
testing there's a lot of test objects
wait but they don't don't they get paid
out though
sure but they're still lining up like if
i was attached to
an intubator thing i would want to get
this back that's true
that's true true i'd rather line up to
get the new iphone
that's true very true that's true
double true on that well well
the vaccine is linked up to the 5g
network so you need to get both
because that's how they are going to
control you okay true
true but here's here's the good news
though here's some
numbers and i don't know if we believe
it or not
but uh moderna's if efficacy rate is at
94.5 percent
so if you so if you catch covin you have
covid
you have the injection you have a 94.5
of just ridding it all together and you
don't have to suffer through whatever
symptoms you get from covid what's the
percentage of just getting better from
it do you know that by any chance and
then like how long does it take usually
like i want to know these recoveries
because i know some people that got it
and then it was like literally like
they're
gone in a day yeah and they're healthy
and it's fine
oh yeah yeah yeah it seems like it's
ranging all over the place like
out of all the things i've read so far
it seems like there's no
clear-cut evaluation that is the same
like you know it's like some people
literally die from it get it really bad
and like in two days they're dead yeah
and then some people get over it within
hours like they catch it and they have
like fatigue that they can't taste
my brother got it and he couldn't taste
and your dad
and my dad my dad actually got the like
flu-like symptoms and stuff he was
bedridden and stuff
but he he's okay now and maybe he's like
technically has an antibody for it now
probably yeah
yeah technically so then so that was
like a week of like flu-like symptoms
from my dad and my brother like he said
it was like a week of not being able to
taste anything that's it they did it
you can taste now you could taste fine
though was it bedridden or anything
no no for some people too they have
lingering like
effects after like a six months still
like they're
they can't breathe right they can't
taste right one of my aunts got uh
she wasn't able to hear she was
intubated and she was like early
in the in the coronavirus she lost
hearing out of her right ear she has to
wear a hearing aid
and now i think she has like she lost
like slight vision girl how old is she
she was like 40. oh geez yeah and she
was like she's pretty healthy she's
pretty young
i miss someone that lost a lung oh my
gosh
yeah she was taking a bike course with
me and then she's like oh i can't go
uphill
because the coronavirus she lost yeah
and then so she was taking a bike class
because she's like i had to do something
with my life
when she recovered she's like i want to
do some more activity because i only
have one lung
[ __ ] yeah so she wanted to strengthen
that one lung you know that makes sense
what if she burns out that lung yeah i
wonder if she could even like float
evenly like she's in the
water just below this blue side goes up
i don't know
she's a perpetual that's actually a
reasonable question i want to know
because she only has one inflatable
device
do they take out the lung if it doesn't
work anymore maybe
oh i don't know how it works i didn't
ask her there's also those eye
or is it iron lines the ones that have
like the fake lungs like
like it's like a big iron bed right yeah
i want a better lung you shouldn't have
smoked so much
i know you've got good lungs dude yeah
crazy good cardio is that where your
lung is
up here in your heart they're here
yeah i thought they were under yeah
they're by your diaphragm well i gotta
go like this and then you get a labor
right here
your legs are huge actually it's like
from here to here i love my lungs oh
[ __ ]
huge your actual lungs yeah my lungs are
[Laughter]
we're talking about lungs i feel like i
can't breathe i know huh i practice
breathing deeper because i think i got
used to
short breaths from weed and smoke
and everything whatever like i don't
ever actually
take a full inhale and it feels so nice
but then when you visualize
you like inhaling and then like filling
up your stomach and then moving up and
filling up your lungs and then keep
going until you feel it like fill it to
your brain
and then you release you get like
intense like relaxation
i do the wim hof breathing techniques
where you do
30 deep breaths and then you hold your
breath for a minute and a half and then
you release that [ __ ]
and then you pass off that one that's
like this
yeah with your stomach oh yeah that one
i don't know what that is
pepper ventilation yeah it's when you so
if you slow it down it's like
like how to say like inhale and make
make your stomach big and then you
exhale and goes all the way in but you
do it really fast
yeah that's a technique breathing
they tell us to do that yoga class yeah
it's a kundalini thing kundalini
yeah that's what it is there's this
tibet
tibetan like breathing competition
tibetan
breathing or whatever like all these
monks get together and they have layers
of like blankets and then they
it's cold as [ __ ] right and just from
breathing
they try to see how many layers they can
sweat through
whoa do they all snuggle but it's cold
up there you know what i mean it's like
[ __ ] ice our bodies are [ __ ]
amazing you know just with breathing you
can also
make yourself hallucinate with enough
oxygen or
uh with like a breathing technique like
you have to like i don't i've never done
it but i would think less oxygen because
like when you get drunk that's what it
does is cut off the oxygen from your
brain
so that's why you feel all like yeah
because your lungs are processing
alcohol as well oxygen you know what i
heard i heard the cause of a lot of our
anxiety is because we
sit so much and our uh bodies are like
we're scrunching up the diaphragm and
we're like in this position
and we're not breathing and we feel
trapped physically
so then our mind starts feeling trapped
physically that makes sense because
whenever i have anxiety i have to lay on
the floor with all my back and you feel
free
physically i have to jack off is that
oxygen yeah are you jacking up like this
are you talking about
this crowd i do it proudly yeah
in the living room standing up so i
don't get like tight hip flexors have
you guys ever
do you guys ever think you had corona
buyers during this time yeah but in the
very beginning we think we all got it
like
there's research now that says november
is probably when it came
yeah did you see those tweets happy
birthday hey guys yeah
happy birthday to corona that's pretty
cool they did a happy birthday corona
that's awesome yeah
what'd you guys do for chronovirus
birthday you guys do anything cool
when was it i quarantined yeah yeah
swallow the celebrity
all three of us uh oh yeah you're corona
babies
what's your favorite birthdays with
karana is corona
scorpio oh man she would be
oh is she what does that mean what
scorpio is your backside
she probably is yeah she's yeah is that
is that what does that tell you about
corona what's her sign yeah what's the
character really jealous
and she's very possessive she's very
possessed she's very possessive and
she won't let us go yeah and she like is
very smart
like very clever she's always adapting
she seems that way yeah she traveled the
whole world really
the web around you she's relentless when
she likes you she doesn't want to let
you go
that's cool that's cool very possessive
well bring on the vaccine so
another big uh like breakthrough with
the vaccine was
and i have a feeling this has something
to do with maybe trying to get the cost
down of the vaccine which is they
figured out how
yeah legitimate in china true
uh they figured out how to get it to be
stable and temperatures common for the
home and medical refrigerators
for up to 30 days so it seems like the
early versions of the vaccine
didn't last very long after production
and it was just kind of like organic
destabilizing it would just kind of like
expire or whatever so now they figured
out
how to make it last for 30 days in
refrigerators and up to six months
in freezers and at room temperature they
last up to 12 hours
nope that wasn't me that was a joke
bar just makes me giggle dude so to six
months you could stay in your freezer i
don't like taking things
but i do i'm not an anti i'm not because
he is he is as a baby i get it like
all those things well you know what i
got the chicken pox naturally though
because they didn't have that
when we were joe doesn't have his
measles yes
we've been having a girl
i got it when i was two like not the
vaccine but the chicken pox
yeah so right after i guess maybe
in in the 90s is when they started
adding that in the vaccine
so the kids they must have been like 95
or something yeah
so like yeah the new i guess gen z or
whatever or like because
isaac never got it right well he got the
vaccine but he never got it
so like kids now they're not gonna ever
know what chickenpox is like
yeah it used to be that thing like where
you ask everybody like when did you get
it no we didn't have parties but like
you know like when did you lose your
first tooth and then like when did you
get your chicken pox like it was like
one of the things where you like keep
tabs like
oh i already got it when i was two like
an icebreaker
yeah like oh i lost my first tooth when
i was six that's funny i remember
thinking i got it for a second time when
i was a kid because i got spots
everywhere i still don't know what it
was but
obviously it's impossible it's
impossible right
i got this i don't think you would get
it twice yeah right it's called uh
shingles when you're good at this
oh i got shingles i thought shingles was
adult yes
it's like old-timey like old people get
shingles what the hell is shingles
not just old but like typically it's a
lot older people right what is it though
it's it's it hurts like a [ __ ]
dude like it's just like it was one of
the most painful things ever like
i had like a little small patch how'd
you get shingles i don't i think it's
like when your immune system is like
really lowered
yeah and this is when i first started
training i found like
british pirates in the 1800s it's like i
got scurvy
too malaria
wear a [ __ ] shirt i would wear a
shirt and like it would rub against my
shingles and would hurt
so bad wow like just think of like the
roof shingles every time give me the
pringles not the shingles
[Music]
you